so ist es die nicht nur 560 liegestütze
gemacht
75 kommen die sales services und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
und zwar habe ich mir gedacht ich mach
relativ oft so sport scheint ist oder
was ist relativ oft habe ich schon zwei
mal gemacht und deswegen möchte ich
heute mal ich ist wahrscheinlich eine
maßlose übertreibung aber ich möchte
heute für jedes modul das sich
abschließe fünften liegestützen machen
das heißt wenn es gut läuft für mich und
da ist das erste modul muss sich einfach
in einer runde 10 x 15 150 schützen
machen dann würde ich mein leben
aufgebraucht
damit melden erster alles gut dabei
150 stück und 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12
größe fuße ok
fertig
es ist eigentlich mit whirlpool aber
wisst ihr was ich werde nach auf die
form zu nehmen gehen aber wo ich meine
frau hat schon mal eine kleine dosis
training aber klar natürlich relativ ist
okay okay freuen sich darauf zu
konzentrieren hat das spiel gedreht ich
schwer sagt auch schon beim zweiten
modul gleich hierdurch wird natürlich
jetzt keine besser aufstellen
aber es wird sicher unterhaltsam option
nummer 22 15 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12 13
14 15 ok wo du nummer zwei alles meine
kopfhörer können ob das mein kopf herum
hier boykottieren ich glaube das größte
problem ist die station von kopfhörer
vom kopfhörer von gaming auf sport
wieder zurück auf gehört was ich halt
gar nicht gebrauchen kann sind so
ultrakurze module mit richtig schlecht
bestückten kisten das der absolute
killer werden ja drauf und 315 stück
12 34 6 10 8 9 10 und 5 1 235 okay ist
langsam fängt sie an zu brennen
durch ein mikrofon
ich hoffe einfach nur dass die legria
jetzt keine probleme macht und sich mir
entscheidet in abgefackelt rate
aufzunehmen weil mein pc 69 ps auf
betraten framerate selbstvergessen heute
bekennen sich arbeiten ihr macht mich
fertig mir bringt mich noch ins grab und
darum ist direkt das nächste modul jetzt
wird es glaube ich hätte echt eklig so
langsam profi killer als cooper dir
alles gut ok
23 47
nach sechs wochen zehn alters brennt
richtig dass print richtig krass zwei
stück noch 14 und 15
okay ich hatte gar boxt das zu machen
ich wollte mal wieder eine richtig
witzige channels machen und ich glaube
ich glaube dass diese challenger
unterhaltsam sein kann oder danke danke
dafür dass diese kiste nicht nur chip
enthält auch nicht statt
ich muss ja auch ein bisschen dafür
engagieren dass gestern dass ihr seht
kein video kam damit wirklich abgefuckte
dass ich gott ich schwöre das mit
absicht
ich schwöre das soll einfach nur
dummheit dass man nicht mit absicht
schöner aussehen
das brennt hat schon richtig gut aber
hey nein ich will es auch nicht den
anderen erwecken dass ich irgendwie
sinnlos rumtrödeln ich bin jetzt
schönste durch als würde ich eine ganz
neue runde spielen
es fällt nur es fällt mir einfach schwer
zu spielen wenn die arme brennen und die
brust brennt
ihr weg wenn die brust band so als wisse
was ich mache einfach keinen vergleich
sollten gütern und denke ich selbst im
vergleich dazu ist ihm nicht klar 560
schon gemacht
75 kommen versuchen die bisschen steuer
zu machen damit wir noch eine kiste
mitnehmen können gut mit ihm aus
ich hoffe die form ist gut
wer nicht allein gestellt werden
natürlich kommen wieder leute so ich
mache sondern ich bin acht jahre alt und
macht man es 1000 flüge klimmzüge sage
ich 20 liegestütze ohne arme einfach nur
mit den beinen
die werden natürlich sicher auch in den
kommentaren kommen an euch schon mal die
begrüßen
aber wo heute das ist ja das ist
wahrscheinlich meine sportlich auf jeden
fall anstrengendste challenge nicht
wahrscheinlich sollen sicher noch keine
change oder so anstrengen die heutige
junge ist das schön kurz tracks modul
alter es ist nicht euer ernst
wisst ihr was ich ziehe einfach man
rüstung an und wieder runter geht
gleichen entschluss
aber was war noch geht 27 also die runde
jetzt ab packt kann schon
ich schwöre minecraft liegt einfach
gratis hier
nein mein kopf wenn es jetzt crash ich
schwöre euch wie das jetzt crash und
chaled kaim
franken
playmate ihr seid ihr seht ihr was ich
hier mache aber hey leute 5 g stürzen
muss noch gemacht werden und die letzte
des heutigen tages sehr schön
ok damit kommen wir auf 90 liegestützen
in zehn minuten geht gar nicht so
schlecht würde ich sagen okay das war es
dann auch soweit vom heutigen video
schon wieder die kamera ihr immerhin
dankeschön an meine tief werde diese
challenge garantiert nicht dass man auf
ihn los sterbe ich das sind erstmal zum
abend kommen noch gern leid das wir sind
vom nächsten video wieder online macht
gut und